welcome back to new rock stars this is
the boys underground
boys only boys masculine energy and one
strong badass female who will be joining
us and dominating us the entire time
the way we like it here the show that
dissects america's the boys
like the guts of a sperm whale just
hanging out for the world to see
we are a rotting whale carcass of a
podcast slash youtube
yes we are a hybrid rotting whale
carcass you can hear it
you can see it and god darn it i bet you
could smell it
the first three episodes of the second
season of the boys just dropped
and in this episode we're digging
through all of them to share some easter
eggs and things you might have missed
we're gonna go through all the kills and
reveals and answer the lingering
questions like
if gills could talk what would they
sound like my guess is pat and oswald
apparently
if i could have a part of my body talk
like pat and oswalt i would and it would
be my nostrils and they would say stop
snorting things anyway with me to share
their thoughts on vaught
get it we rhymed or do rockstar zone
super terrorist or as i prefer
super villain eric ball yes we're still
um focus testing what um super i
am but i think it's uh it's one of those
two
probably either starlight or a super
villain
but nowhere in between and also joining
us as advertised before is the only
person i know
who can explode your head with knowledge
marina marina hello the weird thing
about me being on this show is that i
actually have more testosterone than
tommy and eric combined yeah that's
actually
that's very true blood work done we're
hoping things i've been eating a lot of
salmon and sweet potatoes marina i tell
you
i'm hoping it comes back not even 40 yet
i've been doing a lot of push-ups
you know we're gonna try and get it back
but as for now you're right i've been
listening to joe rogan and so far i have
too much testosterone
just from
yeah yeah it's either that or the 5g
here's a quick recap of what happened in
the first three episodes of season two
this is your spoiler warning if you have
not watched all three episodes
we are going to talk about them all in
this episode so fair warning
if you haven't watched them it's about
to get real so in episode one homelander
and starlight host translucent
fake funeral and huey plots with
starlight to steal more compound v
to bring to the press the boys hunker
down with frenchie's haitian gang
friends
billy is being framed with for
stillwell's death in
hilarious tv reenactments with what i'm
sure is an authentic
australian actor black noir kills super
terrorists nakib which was kind of to me
a crazy beginning to that episode
because that was one of the things i was
like i wonder how this character is
going to
evolve and it turns out he's going to
evolve with no head on his shoulders
instead edgar is moving the seven into
the department of the defense now the
deep gets approached by eagle the archer
to join the scientology-esque
church of the collective a lot of good
points they made i'm thinking about
signing up that are nexium
homelander laps up stillwell's breast
milk in a very disturbing scene
and pops the eardrums of daredevil
parody blind spot
uh stormfront surprises them as a new
member of the seven she starts off as an
influencer feminist but turns out
is a secret very racist person a lot
like people you follow on twitter that
start out very cool and then you uh say
one thing about equality and they're
like actually
yes uh relevant
super topical they meet with rainer but
her head explodes after she mentions a
coup
uh edgar tells homelander about vaught's
nazi roots and its true priority as a
pharmaceutical company
and that's episode one which uh had us
off and running i felt uh
sure yes indeed all right episode
two billy returns to the group and he
says a lot of words that i can't say but
he's from another country
so he can get away with it with a
charming accent but boy if i could i
still wouldn't say them because i
am not that kind of person he's trying
to remember details about becca's
location
he's writing it down on a cute little
tony cicero's playmat
becca is keeping homelanders son ryan in
the gated vaught compound and freaking
out that homelander is trying to insert
himself in as a father figure
tough to come back in a child's life
after being absent for
eight or nine years i would know my kids
don't talk to me and i don't even have
superpowers so
we'll talk to you daddy tom yeah yeah
so the boys track down a telekinetic
super terrorist who ends up being
kimiko's brother kenji
a train finally comes out of his coma
and threatens to tell on starlight and
also no one ever wears anything other
than their soup outfits
i know right the costumers were like hey
guys we spent a lot of money on these
costumes can we
do we just assume that starlight in her
apartment is still wearing her shoe rock
costume
zuckerberg has sworn by that steve jobs
swore by that it's called the uniform
you wear the same thing every day and
that's less time spent
on image that's right and also
simultaneously cultivating an image like
me
yeah i always wear like clothes like i'm
about to work out and i never work out
but the image i'm putting out is
i'm ready for getting a sweat on at any
point on to episode three
all right homelander gives ryan the
worst flying lesson this is like when my
dad put me on a bike with no training
wheels it just
fired me down hightower away off the
roof yeah yeah
i went off a roof and then and then he
refused to let my mom resuscitate me
an angry ryan then throws homelander off
becca so home writer wasn't wrong ryan
is a chip off the old
uh horrible block the media learns about
vaught using compound v to create
soups that's a huge scandal uh billy
apprehends kenji on a boat they're on a
boat
and then offers to trade him to the cia
in exchange for becca things go wrong
and they end up plowing his people
through deep's well which he has named
lucy now it seems like
throughout the show the deep learns that
these animals all have names which to me
implies that all animals around us have
names for each other and they're
christian white names yeah like wouldn't
it wouldn't the whale's name be like
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's your whale name comment down
below using only vowels
all right so the seven that's when the
seven catches up with the boys they
follow them into the storm dream
homelander tries to force starlight to
kill huey a really
difficult choice for her kenji then
smashes homeland during a heroic moment
but storm front
catches up to him breaks his hands snaps
his neck and then for good measure
puts a really gross cherry on top by
uttering a racial slur
the episode ends with edgar claiming no
knowledge of compound v
and stormfront stealing the spotlight
makes her a target for homelanders wrath
and also obviously the vengeful wrath of
kimiko
is uh on their on their way so what do
you guys think overall
really cool also um can we just
very quickly go back to the baby thing
because that's where we left off right
and so the baby didn't die baby didn't
die
the baby didn't die and the baby was
transported what 17 miles away
yeah they said yes um safely and
so even though where we left off last
time
last episode of our show the boys
underground was
i will never forgive billy butcher and
he didn't kill the kid but here's why
i'm still never gonna forgive him
is because he's not the one who saved
the kid
or is he we we don't know what exactly
happened
but marina you are right you are right
and that he was willing to kill that kid
which is
president yeah yeah so that's who did we
learn
uh in these episodes is moderately
explosion proof
uh that would be black noir that's right
apparently a character that we have seen
very small doses of empathetic sadness
and grief
despite being completely non-verbal i
mean you you get
he's kind or he or they whoever we don't
know i guess it could be a she
uh is uh has these like small moments of
emotion that lead you to believe that
there's a lot more going on
under this they were very sad to find
out they were not a natural superhero
yeah yes very sad true and uh i'll say
that like the first episode i thought
was great
episode two did feel a bit like filler
just kind of just my feelings on it but
like the the new characters as they're
coming in super interesting i love this
uh church of the collective subplot
i'm fascinated to see where that goes
and uh man the stormfront
at the beginning i'm like okay i can get
on board with you but
boy oh boy now do i hate her and want
her to die
yes wait really i i i she is so the fact
that she
and private had to drop in that racist
line
like oh obviously we hate her i think
it's so
interesting yeah interesting yes like
interesting like it's kind of like
you love to hate right yeah and and i
think
it uh tell me what you guys think this
so this first three episodes i'm
wondering this whole time why did gus
spring uh
bring stormfront in right like
he chose her why her why her because
she's talking
[ __ ] on vaught like she's not following
you know pr orders like and this whole
time i'm going like why why why why why
and at the end when she turns out to be
basically
the only thing that can keep homelander
in check
i was like oh that's why yeah yeah
because
she apparently has super strength right
just like
crushes bones uh and has electricity
which might be the only thing
to combat laser eyes i think there's
some there's
something even deeper to her that like
uh when we go through the
easter eggs uh there's i think there's
something more there that's even
creepier
yeah i i thought overall her character
is a really fascinating kind of like
enhanced powered version of like the
influencer
on on uh the especially like the free
thinking influencer on social media that
will say a lot of stuff that's like
wow what an outsider perspective yeah
what a cool skill
this person has on like and then you
peel one onion layer back and you're
like oh a foundation in racist and
obviously the name
stormfront yeah carries all sorts of
racial connotations i'm sure we'll go
into
well i almost knocked my computer off
because uh the stormfront people got to
me
uh all right so this would not be a new
rock stars video
without our man pretty ricky eric voss
pointing out
some easter eggs things you might have
missed in moments when
flies worked their way into the show
eric what do you got for us yes
uh i'm gonna break down some of the the
bigger easter eggs obviously
every frame of the show has like
references to other things and they do a
really good job with the world building
the production design
i'm just gonna break down the really
really important ones across these three
episodes i'm gonna skip over like the
obvious stuff like
seth rogen and chris hanson cameoed in
there all right first thing
at translucent's funeral in episode one
yeah it was obviously faked his cause of
death
you know the corpse in the casket do you
see how it was like
rigged to look like something was
weighing down those cushions
yeah like his body is in smithereens
like there's
they did there's nothing in there either
they just ironed it down in some way or
they they had cushions that looked like
they were weighted
i just thought there was some nice
attention to detail
but uh second detail i thought was
really interesting when homelander and
starlight are talking to reporters
outside the funeral
they have these kind of scripted
responses where he's like oh it comes in
waves and then she goes we're a family
and they show up those phrases show up
on the tv chiron immediately as they say
those lines
just a little attention to detail
showing that they're just reading the
script that
tv news crew has the same exact script
but there's another moment that's
happened in these three episodes
late in the episode when stormfront is
meeting with homelander and maeve on the
set of that um
that propaganda taping uh her instagram
live comments
have like a super fast reaction time
when when maeve says oh are you from
seattle and then
immediately a comment says she's from
portland
there's no way an instagram live would
be able to
read it that fast it could just be an
editing thing because yeah you know are
the editors of the show really paying
attention that much
well there's another detail so there's a
a few
subtle moments this is our third detail
where storm front appears to be reading
someone's mind it's not certain but we
think she might also be a mind reader
there's a moment right in that scene
where she's looking at homelander and
her eyes narrow
the actress does such a great job of
this uh and there's also a moment when
she and starlight are on the um
the press junket and she gives starlight
a similar kind of look
and at the end of episode three she and
homelander are staring each other down
and it seems like
the edge that she might have of her
homelander is that she can
be a minder she can uh she's telepathic
um so maybe in that moment she was
reading maeve's mind
but then you're saying well then why are
the instagram live commenters saying it
i think those commenters might be fake
people they might be fake accounts
that she like the nazis say oh we have
this silent majority of people who agree
with us
but she has all these fake accounts that
she's like conducting all these
supportive
things oh yeah she's just russia
she really is fourth detail um episode
one opens with billy joel's pressure
and then uh billy joel's your only human
is a big part of episode two and three
obviously calling back huey's debate
with robin about billy joel that was
their
final conversation they had so i'll be
interested to see if billy joel's in
every single episode this season
um yes also i might be reading into this
as i often do here at new rockstars but
there definitely seemed to be a parallel
at least in episodes two and three with
billy
butcher and captain jack sparrow now go
with me on this
they call him the captain of the team he
has a similar cockney accent
he's self-serving he steals a boat
and at the bottom line of all this
captain jack another billy joel song so
be very captain jack will get you high
tonight
yeah hi tonight
yes i'm sold
we'll see if he turns into a skeleton
when the moon shines on him
oh then we're there you're in one
do you believe in ghost stories miss
turner yes
um all right next detail during huey and
starlight's opening meet up when they're
walking through the town they're meeting
in the subway there are posters all over
the place and
all these are very important so uh first
you see a post for terminal beauty three
that was pop claws movie
that's just kind of a little throwaway
one but there's also a poster for autumn
breeze by
liberty it's like a pharmaceutical or
it's like a perfume
or a cosmetic thing liberty is that
old-school soup that they talk about
more on her and about yeah yes um and
then there was a newspaper that a guy
was reading there's a headline about
shockwaves setting the speed record
and he was in talks to join the seven
maybe as a backup to a train
uh he was at speedster rival in season
one when they had the race
yeah so uh and they had mentioned in uh
marketing for this season that there's
gonna be
uh two possible speed characters so he
he's probably gonna play a bigger role
um and then in that subway car there's
also a poster for the church of the
collective that's the scientology group
that the deep ends up with
yes so what we talked about in our last
episode of the boys underground was the
fly
right the mysterious fly from season one
and a lot of fans of the show were like
this isn't gonna be anything it was just
an accident
but they keep doubling down on it so
there's a few references
in these episodes uh there's another fly
that shows up
buzzing around a light that they amp up
the audio so you hear it's buzzing
and then minutes later in episode one
you see a tv and on the sidebar
there is a shout out for suatto that is
the comics life-size
soup who just speaks in buzzing noises
but i really do think they could be
adapting swado
to be a fly-sized ant-man style soup
that has been spying on
throughout the whole time cool you can
also
see a fly buzzing around um the carcass
of lucy the whale in episode three
that would make sense it is a giant
mammal carcass but
it's a fly and any time there's a fly
sighting in the show we're going to add
it to the list
suado we also talked about the breaking
bad parallels
obviously giancarlo esposito but the
church of the collective woman carol
that's played by jessica hecht
who played gretchen schwartz on breaking
bad oh
yeah the reason waltz eventually broke
bad on that series yes
and then uh the names we talked about
stormfronts instagram live feed all the
names are
interesting nods to other things so
there's one that's uh based on
big game that's the suit from season one
he also gets a shout out from starlight
and gecko they they used to work
together
and big game was pontius pilate uh and
then pop claw there's a reference to
jack from jupiter that's the previous
member of the seven
from the from the series premiere uh
there's some references to lamplighter
and ezekiel
now there's one comment though that says
hello from argentina
which i think has got to be a clue to
stormfront's
nazi maybe background because you know
in history
a lot of the members of the ss relocated
to argentina
um and then on this subject stan edgar
lectures homelander about
frederick vaught's nazi experiments with
compound v before he relocated to the
u.s and i'm thinking stormfront maybe
could be an ageless nazi experiment
maybe she even kind of like and get out
she could have frederick vaught's
mind inside her body and that's why she
has these old-school nazis because she
also
the type of racial slur she uses is yeah
it's not one that a modern-day
influencer would use if they wanted to
be anti-aging yeah
but coming back to liberty um that was
it looks like a world war ii era soup
and grace mallory
is asking about her and she's like i
don't know if she's connected to this
but she's looking at a liberty in a
budweiser magazine ad
which i found to be very weird you may
have some history buffs who like
check me on this but like during the mid
40s you would not see
ads for a german beer company there
weren't
many beer advertisements at all because
prohibition had only ended a decade
earlier
and the advertising industry didn't
really exist to this level
sophistication
it's very very weird to see liberty
selling like a patriotic american
selling a budweiser ad
during world war ii it did there's a lot
of anti-german sentiment in the country
at that time
um but also kimiko's brother kenji wears
a specific shirt that is spuds mckenzie
that is the old bud light campaign
and he has a star on his hat oh yeah
similar iconography
and associations as liberty so it's very
interesting that mallory
wanted kenji that that was part of the
deal but was also curious in that same
conversation about liberty
well it's also interesting that
stormfront swooped in to kill this
character
despite homelander calling dibs oh right
so
connecting all the dots on this my
theory is that
the compound v formula the one that has
created all these soups in the modern
era was derived
from a specific version of it that they
got to from those world war ii nazi
experiments
and liberty was frederick vaught's first
successful soup his mind
carried on in her body carrying on that
nazi ideology
and then later never aging becoming the
woman we now know
as stormfront the actress who placer
is jewish so uh i think i think kenji
was going to be evidence of a more
direct link
from the compound v derivation to that
dark
nazi history interesting yes aya cash
great actress you're the worst
yep she was awesome and you're the worst
yep um okay moving right along when
billy wakes up at fort wayne in episode
two this is a small one but he's at a
tony cicero's italian restaurant that
was the same chain that he and frenchie
and huey killed translucent in
in in season one that was also to tony
ciceros um
and then homelanders super heats of
course some of um
stillwell's breast milk and then lapse
it up like a dog and then just chugs it
but every time we see him drinking
thereafter it is
milk and uh during breakfast in episode
three
anthony's star he does that great like
us he enjoys it too much
he loves milky way too much and then he
kind of calls that back later when he
taunts billy about getting breakfast
with his family
and he says it was delicious it wasn't
just to
piss him off it was like to remind
himself how much he loves the taste of
milk
that was just a really gross unsettling
thing okay and we also learned in these
three episodes that beck and ryan are on
this gated compound right it was uh it's
kind of like a truman show
set up and i think this was to raise
ryan
with a normal home life after vaught had
screwed up homelanders so bad
by not giving him a family that he can
learn here from
um then episode one kind of gives you
tips it's hand a little bit that they're
doing that
when home later knocks on the door there
is just this weird security camera
that's just
out of focus right in frame kind of like
all the cameras that are hidden in the
background a truman show
and then a little one when the marketing
guy's pitching batman v superman on a
justice type movie with
the seven dawn of the seven he describes
the handheld style he wants to use his
very green grass
which is an interesting description
because paul greengrass directed
real-life hijacking crisis movies like
united 93
captain phillips two movies that ended
super dark
just like homelanders flight crash
incident or any of the times he is
horrifically slaughtered armed militants
the way
captain phillips ended with tom hanks
screaming and says that what is in mine
and we all cried a little bit and like
give him another oscar and then
it has been very interesting to watch
blackmore this season i think we got to
keep our eye on him when he watched the
reports of compound v's manufacture
and he learned that he was made he cried
and some people thought he was laughing
but if you look at closed captioning it
said sobbing and then when the deep was
crying about lucy the whale notice how
you know black moore passes chest and
respect
and then as they head into the tunnels
he and homelander exchange this very
interesting look and i won't go further
i don't want to say more about this but
just like keep your eye on black moore
there's something
very weird he's getting humanized a lot
uh and uh he has some weird connection
here uh in the last detail i just have
to point out i'm sorry this is
self-indulgent but
um shout out to off-screen producer zach
he actually spotted this when stormfront
and kenji are smashing through the
apartment building on the tv's
basketball game
where is it set at the odome home of me
and zack's alma mater the florida gators
three episodes worth of questions in
this episode
uh and so let's take a look at some
questions and mysteries that we'll be
keeping our eyes on
as the season unfolds so who do you guys
think blew up raynor's head and why was
she killed
just a quick thought on this i think she
was killed right after she mentioned
that she believes there's a coup
and i think the coup she's talking about
is a us government coup
i think that's what she wants to uh she
wants the seven
to be in the um department of defense
and i think if you can have martial law
declared
and maybe one of them rises up to be
secretary of defense and enough of the
other um line of succession is killed
off one of them becomes president so
either one of them or someone
there's also this congresswoman that
they keep showing she could be like a
sympathetic figure to the seven who
becomes who runs for president
i think that's the coup that's going on
yes a soup in the white house so that's
why i still don't know who though
i it must have been some telepathic
person who blew her head up i don't
think it was a neck bomb or a
skull bomber i was wondering because her
nose bled yeah
that was like if she had like an implant
or something like if they oh
but uh yeah i don't know that was
interesting you know
eric since you were talking about how
stormfront
could possibly have um mind reading
abilities it's theoretically possible
that if she has that she could have the
ability of like telekinesis to just like
you know what i mean or it could it
could
she could only have the ability to read
minds and blow up minds like she can't
blow up anything else
i can read i can pop she can only blow
she can
either yeah well what is specific
ability
and i'll say uh for me the nose started
bleeding that's a dead giveaway that a
fly flew into her nostril
and planted an explosive device it all
comes back to swaddle baby very popular
i just realized i
have a cabinet open in the background
good lord
i think it's falling apart ghost in the
kitchen oh my god
yeah next question how did homelander
transport butcher
to fort wayne and how did stillwell's
baby survive
okay so having not read the comics right
like as a just a pure
viewer right coming in fresh
uh to me homelander is a parallel to
just a bad superman
like he's superman but he's bad right we
haven't really explored
that uh homelander is super fast we know
he's a super fast flyer we see him break
sound barriers and have sonic booms so
what if we just haven't
discovered that he's also super fast
running
or he could have just scooped the baby
up with his arms and then flew
away right so he could have saved the
kid and
he could have done it because he also
secretly knows
that that's his kid again
[Music]
i mean because like she he's drinking
her titty milk anyway
so like there's no way they haven't yeah
i think that there's very likely that
those two had had intercourse before
yeah
yeah which is the real mystery that
we're here to solve
and let me let me show you the drawings
there's a character that we have hinted
at um
that might be involved in that like
someone we know might have also been in
that house
that's all i'll say right now the other
half of my theory is that stillwell
obviously like has this baby and
you know 99.999 is that it's a
it's a v baby like it's a super baby so
if homelander knows that he's he fries
her
brains he scrambled eggs her head right
and then
he would have saved that baby anyway
just to
have a control of another suit
potentially
to raise as his own to sell to you know
to whatever
but every suit baby is valuable so it
totally makes sense to me that he would
say that anybody around would have saved
that baby except for
billy butcher next question
what's with the fresca and what's its
connection to the church of the
collective
don't get me wrong i love a good fresco
but i uh um
why do they love it i have two thoughts
on this one is that like fresca is
something that a
creepy weird brainwashed cult would
drink fresca is disgusting
it's like a weird somewhere someone
working for fresca right now is like
we paid for this product placement by
the way i love i love fresco and send it
by the gallon
weird it's a weird like uh instead of a
white claw or lacroix or something like
that someone's like how about a fresca
and it's like
get away from me a psychopath um
[Laughter]
my thinking is that like there might be
something in that there might be
something
and the way that a lot of cults whether
it's heaven's gate jonestown
uh something in the water at the church
of scientology for sure yeah
i think they may have something that's
in there that's gradually uh
uh and what's the rajnishi's in oregon
did this as well they tried to like
poison the town water supply right that
was part of that
so it's kind of a recurring thing with
colts so i'm thinking there might be
something there
last question why is homelander letting
both edgar and stormfront alpha him
we pick up with a couple theories maybe
there's like um a telepathy going on
there
i think right now um homelanders
realizing
that like he didn't really put together
that uh compound b was
creating superheroes still yeah like he
was behind the curve on that
i'm thinking he's realizing oh my powers
came from a play from a history
that i do not fully understand so
edgar and stormfront might have some
checks on my power that i
i don't fully appreciate yet so i'm oh
sure abide my time
yeah it does it stands to reason that
that edgar knows homelanders weaknesses
that we have not learned yet like yeah
there's a because otherwise i feel like
homelanders
that lost his cool enough times around
him he would have killed him by now so
yeah like
i fear i was waiting for him to do it in
that scene i was like is he
done like whoa yeah just reasoning like
if he's developed
compound v to be the thing that creates
superheroes he could easily just reason
like he also is probably someone who's
created a kryptonite
yeah yeah you would think he would yeah
just as a you know security
insurance policy all right well
certainly we'll have more questions than
answers
next week but before we get out of here
it's time for a very important segment
because as we know living is easy
it's the dying part that's hard so i
think it's the other way around
in hamilton dying is easy living is hard
that's what i meant
uh anyway marina you're gonna break down
all the kill counts ranking from most
kills
or yeah least kills to most kills what's
the kill count on this
these three episodes i gotcha uh all
right so
i counted up the carnage for all three
of these episodes and
tallied up who was killing who so i'm
gonna count them down for you so number
seven
uh with one kill is billy butcher uh
which is the funniest one of all and
also i loved it it's but it's also the
least realistic is
lucy the whale because if you
if you drove a boat into a whale that
whale would
bounce you off yeah it'd be like a
trampoline
yeah every single person on that boat
would have just been flown into the air
and just super dead like they'd all be
absolutely
dead but it's a fun way to you know
it's fun and they got to sit inside the
well for a while so i let it go for sure
uh number six homelander maybe maybe one
kill
of blind spot uh because he popped his
ears like a bad like a naughty child
um but i'm with uh i'm with you tommy
because
that was a lot of blood that was a lot
of blood and if he didn't die in that
scene
he he would have made sure like
homelander has a reputation to worry
about right
yeah absolutely he would have followed
up yeah oh what a horrible thing to do
to someone who
has learned to use their eardrums it it
honestly reminded me of that moment to
kill bill where she plucks out the eye
and now she's like lying to both eyes
it's just like rolling around
screaming yeah you just feel kind of bad
for them not me though
number five
uh the mystery killer right so one kill
is the cia deputy director
rainer yeah yeah you don't know for sure
but they're on the
they're on the murder map on the murder
map good let's put them on the board
yep so number four is chemical
with one kill and it's the old guy in
the party store
who is of course part of the terrorist
group or whatever you want to call them
that
um killed her parents so she of course
very satisfyingly
snaps this guy's neck vengeance it
tastes
so good and number three is
kenji so who has three kills uh
or three plus actually so he dropped the
boat on the
haitian gang member whose arm was all
cool
yeah that really they they did a good
job with that i was like
yeah uh that guy we we can safely assume
that he died because they were
pretty unwilling to take him to the
hospital i'd be like take me to the
hospital
but they're like nah bruh and then he
also uh we can assume
killed everybody in the nypd uh
helicopter crew although
i think that um that we're keeping this
kill count for now but
remains to be seen because huey throws a
life preserver overboard and i think
that
is a metaphor for not only his humanity
that is staying intact
but also could be a foreshadowing of
like maybe
one of those people does survive and
is able to tell what happened i read it
as like a useless thing
like uh he's just like they're already
dead and drowning but huey's still
just from his good nature is like oh
this helps me sleep at night
sure there's a good interpretation
different i like it when we have like
different interpretations yeah yeah yeah
um but now shut the [ __ ] up because i'm
gonna keep going number two
black noir
uh uh five kills black noir has five
kills this episode so we start off with
nakeeb
and all his bodyguards and um one of the
women but the best and this is
going to be my pick for um like grossest
most satisfying the thing that made me
go like the most
was uh like the reverse curb stomp which
was like grabbing someone's
teeth yikes
it's not funny but i'm laughing because
that's why that's why i have this job is
because these things are hilarious to me
uh great and so number one for this guys
is
storm front so she has 13 plus
kills she kills that family in the
apartment
she kills that girl just for screaming
and the guy who's in the hallway and we
see a bunch of explosions and we hear
screams in that building
which i'm gonna like guesstimate is
about eight more
um and then she kills kenji in front of
kimiko
and um yeah it was she she's
she's up there it took us a while for
homelander to rack up the kills
but she's just like starting off with
13.
so yeah i don't see them as like a like
this kind of a thing
absolutely and you know what like
homelander they're both different kinds
of evil
homelanders seems to only kill people
when he has something to lose or
something to gain from it
yeah she's just killing like recklessly
and wantonly
like she doesn't need to none of those
people are gonna be that mad
uh if like they just crashed through her
home but she just doesn't know anyway
yeah she's like you're screaming too
loud boy right yeah
this is very messed up yeah super super
super
f'ed up ending uh speaking of left up
endings that's it
that's our show uh so great to chat with
you guys eric and marina always a
delight
always a delight uh tune in every week
to hear our reactions for the latest the
boys episode of the boys underground
please subscribe to the boys underground
on itunes
or wherever you get your podcasts you'll
get the show earlier than the video
version
and it's a huge help to us a new
rockstar so honestly please
if you if you if you're a podcast person
hit us up and remember to join our
official discord
by becoming a patron at patreon.com new
rockstars
on discord we'll be fielding the
questions that we answer on the show so
it's a great way to get involved
if you want to be part of the
conversation or if you just like to
watch
throw a question out anonymously and
then see if we answer it and then cackle
to yourself like swatto
cackling as he exploded rainer's head
you can follow me
at tommy bechtold you can follow eric at
ea boss follow marina marina mastros
follow new rockstars on all the socials
subscribe here on youtube to get too
much information on all the stuff that
you care about
go bills and god bless america and go
gators
go gators go murder homelander
go america
[Music]
you